[Music]
hello and welcome to worlds apart
there's an old persian saying when
there's fire dry
and wet burn together it may be an apt
description of the covet 19 pandemic
which
affected every country on the planet but
iran and the united states
more than others can this new invisible
anime which appended so many things in
our lives shake
up this sworn and tired enmity
well to discuss that i'm now joined by
iran's foreign minister javad zarif
minister it's such a pleasure to see you
in moscow especially in person
good to see you again you know you're
one of the first and very few
dignitaries who are flying into moscow
this day and i want to start you by
asking how
has this pandemic changed the workings
of diplomacy do you guys
have zoom conversations like most of us
or
is it deemed not particularly safe to
exchange information this way
well actually we have to do that and
just this morning i participated in the
meeting of the conference on interaction
and cooperation in asia confidence
building in asia
by a video conference and
there were some 20 more foreign
ministers who were participating
in that conference and as you pointed
out in your
in your introductory statement uh
this this virus doesn't recognize rich
or poor
weak or strong or enemies it's affecting
all of us
uh and it shows that we need to come
together in order to fight this virus
unfortunately the united states
continues
to prevent iran even from buying
medicine
and vaccine to buy this fire we will
definitely discuss that in details but
let me ask you one more question about
the workings of diplomacy because from
what you mentioned i understand that
when it comes to
you know making uh public statements or
prepared statements
it's okay to do it uh online but you
still came to moscow for some reason is
that because uh
certain things are too sensitive to
discuss yes this is this is actually my
third visit to moscow
after the corona breakout so
uh there are things that you need to
discuss in person
uh of course we we all use video
conferencing
zoom or whatever other
platforms that are available but it
comes to a point that you need to
discuss certain things in person
now under normal conditions a diplomat
of your
statute would be granted full immunity i
mean you cannot be searched you cannot
be tested
uh has covered 19 change any of that i
mean
are you required to do you require your
peers your counterparts to provide some
proof of
them not being a health risk to others
well
we don't do that to diplomats in in iran
but
and i was not uh subjected to any of
those measures
no but but in some other countries they
do
some countries require you to go through
at least a temperature check
some countries require you to provide
them with
a test that was taken
[Music]
no more than 48 hours before you you
arrived
but those are much fewer china is for
instance one of those countries that has
very strict
requirements i'll be going to china in a
in a couple of weeks and i
it's not going to be easy now iran is
one of the hardest hit
countries in the middle east some
experts suggest that you are now in the
grips of
a third wave of the pandemic and many
high-ranking iranian officials
succumbed or even died from the virus i
know that one of your closest
uh advisors and friends and former
colleagues
sadly uh died because of it uh i wonder
if you
personally have developed any rules or
routines to maximize your safety because
you
you are in a high-risk job you have many
interactions so
you are in the risk group for sure uh
well uh
we can only try to uh to
stay i mean keep the necessary
not social distancing but physical
distance uh
in in our interactions with the mask and
you do wear the mass because when you
came in here i do i do wear the mask i
do wear the mask all the time
and it's across the board i wear the
mask all of my colleagues wear the mask
it's not as if
i can i can be immune and they they can
have to wear the mask
now you mentioned before uh that there
are difficulties
uh clear difficulties for iran in
securing medical equipment and
they were there even before the pandemic
struck
how severe they are now and is it a
factor in
why the pandemic affected your country
so severely
well certainly the sanctions and
economic hardship that the united states
imposed on iran
has had a significant impact
on two levels first
we had to we could not keep people from
going to work
we could not provide them with subsidies
with extra subsidies we already do
provide subsidies
but we couldn't provide them with extra
subsidies or incentives
to stay home people had to to earn a
living and and the government's
coffers were not that well
filled so we need we needed to allow
them to
to earn their their own living this was
this was the first
decision that we had to make a very hard
decision but a decision nevertheless
that we needed to
to adopt and secondly the second
level is buying medicine buying the
vaccine
the united states first of all limited
our financial resources by preventing us
from
selling oil and secondly it is
preventing
us even from having access to our own
money we have quite a bit of money
uh stashed in countries abroad and
those countries are prevented by the
united states
from even allowing us to buy medicine
with our own money whatever the
americans are saying about
their sanctions not affecting
humanitarian items
it's just it's just a lie we have been
trying to
transfer money for the coveted 19
kovacs the the the who vaccine
we haven't been able to do that we've
been trying to transfer money even for
normal influenza vaccines where the
united states restrictions prevent us
from even
transferring money to to buy vaccines so
it's it's basically medical terrorism
that the us is engaged in now you know
in moscow for
what i assume uh some sensitive
conversations since you came here in
person and i'm pretty sure that you are
going to touch
with your russian colleagues on the
latest u.s
decision to reimpose arms embargo
against
your country now everybody except the
united states agrees that it's legal so
we don't have to waste
your valuable time on uh talking about
the illegitimacy of that
act i want to ask you and i want to get
an honest assessment from you whether
you think it would still be
effective despite being illegal does the
united states have the means
of imposing not only imposing that ban
on your country but
effectively making it international well
the united states
does certainly have uh a lot of uh
might financial might er in
when it comes to preventing countries
from dealing with each other
and that is why countries are less and
less
dependent on dollar because they know
that as long as they
depend for their international
transaction on u.s dollars
they are basically at the mercy of the
united states
and the americans can can impose their
whims uh on them second point
on this is this is a principle for us
iran doesn't buy a lot of arms
we're not saudi arabia i mean they they
spent
67 billion dollars more than russia did
uh
on on their uh military uh
we don't spend that much money uh we
don't have that much money to spend
we produce most of the weapons we need
ourselves so we're not going to go to
international markets uh to to try to
procure
weapons from here and there none of the
european countries
even sold those weapons since the since
the revolution
so we're not under any illusions uh but
this is a principle
that there was an agreement to lift uh
the restrictions
and as russia correctly has pointed out
we did not we were not under an arms
embargo there were restrictions we
needed to get
a permission from the security council
to buy and sell weapons
and now that restriction will be lifted
uh
in mid-october and that that is
the most important thing if we need to
procure weapons to buy weapons from our
friends
then there are no legal limits well
speaking of your friends and buying arms
from that when
your russian counterpart sergey lavrov
was asked whether
russian arms producers will continue
trading with iran he said that he could
not give an answer because it's a
private business decision and the
americans do have an ability to
influence the calculus of risks i want
to ask you specifically what kind of
reaction you're expecting from russia
and china is the
rhetorical condemnation enough
russia and china took the lead in
objecting to to the american measures
but for that matter
even the europeans i mean 13 members 13
of the 15
security council members twice wrote
letters to the
president of the security council once
on the 20th of august when the united
states
issued its so-called notification and
once on the 20th of september when the
united states
claimed that it's purported u.n
sanctions have come back
rejecting it and that's what's uh
important i
i think that's that that's the important
uh
point uh just a diplomatic sense is
enough
but yeah i mean that's a major
diplomatic defeat for the united states
isolation of the united states
verification by the international
community of the legitimacy of iranian
position which is an important
achievement not just for iran but for
the international community and for the
rule of law
now we have uh contacts at the military
level
with our friends those contacts will
continue uh
and usually these are not broadcast live
on television
i see you mentioned the european
reaction and i do want to ask you about
the europeans because i think russia
now nowadays finds itself in a situation
similar to the one that iran was with
the gcpoa
because it has invested in the pipeline
in the north stream pipeline and now it
sees
the europeans having second thoughts or
paying
lip service to certain ideas without
actually putting any muscle behind it
uh can the europeans still be regarded
as
this reasonable part of the west because
they definitely talk a different talk
from the united
states but are they more reliable when
it comes to
international agreements and you know
keeping their word
well as you just correctly pointed out
nordstream
is is a very clear example that if
europeans allow the united states to
bully them
when it comes to iran the united states
can bully them when it comes to their
lifeline and north stream is extremely
important for europe as you know
for germany it's its most reliable
energy source
and the and the united states is even
trying to intimidate
clearly intimidate germany from
from engaging with russia in that so i
i think the lesson that has to be drawn
from that
is that if you allow a bully to operate
then there is no limit no end and i
think the europeans need to realize that
now unfortunately up until now europeans
have been doing a lot of good talk
uh on jcpoa on the north stream but
not much much action um i think
i mean we have a long history
and we are patient we know that the
policy of the united states the bullying
policy of the united states
is bound to be rejected by the
international community well
it takes some time but we we have
thousands of years of history we're not
like some countries with 250 years
well i wish i had this uh long view of
history and this kind of afternoons but
for the timing we have to take a short
break so
we'll be back in just a few moments stay
[Music]
tuned
while the pandemic knows certainly no
borders and is blind to nationalities
[Music]
a new virus has emerged we don't have a
therapy we don't have a vaccine
the whole world needs to take action and
be ready it's not a joke people are
dying
god's judgment is coming
the crisis is unprecedented in modern
times
we can do better we should be doing
better
everyone is contributing each in their
own way but we also know
that this crisis will not go on forever
the challenge is great but the response
has been massive so many good people are
helping us
it makes us feel very proud that we're
in it together
[Music]
wall street financial engineers and the
kleptocrats divert
the money printing into their pockets at
a rate that according to the rand
corporation
equals more than 50 trillion dollars so
that is your smoking gun
that's why we have social unrest that's
why we have incredible
wealth and income gap that's why we have
such a distorted economy that's why
wages are not keeping up
that's why we've got inflation raging
that's your smoking gun
end of story
[Music]
welcome back to worlds apart with iran's
foreign minister javad zarif minister
just before the break we're
touched upon um your attitude to
the united states and the there's
a bit more than a month left uh until
the next year's presidential elections i
know that
you say that iran doesn't have a
preferred candidate but as a country
with a long tradition of strategic
analysis i'm sure
you have to foresee different scenarios
do you think there will be a difference
in the u.s policy vis-a-vis your country
depending on who occupies the white
house
come next year well uh
obviously there will be differences
between
various presidents and various points of
views i doubt that any
one will have extreme views such as
president
trump but at the end of the day we need
to look at the policy not the
personality in the white house
now i think the question that needs to
be asked before even uh
asking what their policy will be with
regard to iran
is whether there will be a
peaceful transition in the united states
if
vice president biden uh wins the
election
from what we heard from president trump
yesterday that seems to be a bit more
complicated well i think
his diplomatic contenders are also
pretty unsure whether they're going to
accept his victory so i think it plays
for
you know for both camps perhaps well
let's wait and see i mean the other camp
doesn't have many options
president trump is sitting in the white
house and
for for a sitting president to claim
that his country's elections are going
to be
rigged uh it's it's an interesting
scenario
to watch now uh his contender
or his competitor rather joe biden has
already indicated that
if he wins his administration is willing
to resurrect the
jcpoa to which your country and you
personally
responded by rolling out preconditions
rebuilding trust compensating the
damages which i'm sure you
you know unknown stutters what i want to
ask you is
um regardless of your feelings about the
u.s contact is iran interested in the
covenants of the deal are you interested
in its substance
well of course we are we have said that
with or without the united states
if iranian interests that are
guaranteed in the jcpoa we don't want
anything outside the jcpoa
we simply want what is ours what was
bargained what was negotiated within the
jcpoa and it cannot be renegotiated
we simply want that if the remaining
jcpoa participants can provide that we
are willing to live with that we
gave them particularly the europeans
over here to implement what they had
promised
they made 11 promises at the level of
foreign ministers twice to us
but they were not able to even start
implementing those 11 promises not even
a single one of them
and then we started reducing our
commitments to jcpoa
as was foreseen in the jcpoa so that's
the real dispute resolution
mechanism not the parallel world dispute
resolution mechanism that the united
states is talking about
we are abiding by our obligations we are
within the jcpoa and if
the europeans come back to jcpoa and
implement their
obligations then it's fine jcpoa is
alive
the security council proved that it is a
lie
the united states tried to torpedo this
resolution we were sitting in a room the
united states not only left the room
but bombed the room tried to destroy the
room
now it has to gain a seat back in the
and that is not automatic i'm not
putting any preconditions
i mean you do not want to have a
situation in international
environment where somebody can leave an
agreement
at will and come back to it as well this
doesn't work
i was watching your conversation uh at
the
council of foreign relations and you
repeated this uh wonderful
persian thing a few times uh first you
prove your brotherhood then
ask for inheritance and as well as it
it may be the americans let alone trump
don't leave by
persian wisdom they have their own
philosophy and for the time being
it's a philosophy of taking what they
think is theirs by force
no their philosophy is what's mind is
mind what's yours is negotiable
absolutely that's not the philosophy
that i'm willing to
to succumb to uh you may not be willing
to succumb to but
how do you think what is the effective
way of
dealing with it because whether you like
it or not you still have to
live in a world where this philosophy
you know leaves a significant mark
well i think iran russia and a good
number of other states are not
prepared to allow this philosophy to
become the ruling philosophy
we believe in the rule of law we believe
in the prevalence of international norms
we believe that you when you sign a
treaty you need to
uh abide by it these are what we believe
in otherwise we will have the law
we can operate like that between
ourselves but what about
dealing with the united states we need
to otherwise
it will be a jungle and we're not
prepared to live in a jungle
and i don't think russia is prepared to
live in a jungle i don't think china is
prepared
and i think gradually europe will stop
accepting these dictats from washington
uh switching gears a little bit because
our time is running out i know that you
said before that you are not
very impressed by the recent
agreement between israel and the united
arab emirates as well as bahrain on the
establishment of full diplomatic ties
why not
should i be well they've had
very very strategic secret
connections for the past 15 years the
israeli ambassador in washington uh
i mean put on twitter his picture with
yusuf alva taber the uae ambassador and
said
i'm now happy that i can share with you
a friendship that
we've had for a long time so it was a
friendship that they've had for a long
time
now they had a photo opportunity in the
white house to help trump get reelected
in florida
that may serve that purpose but it
doesn't serve peace but
minister personal or professional
connection is one thing a fully fledged
state relationship is something else no
diverse state relationship
there were state relationships these
relationships
were kept secret now they decided under
trump's son-in-law pressure
to make it public in order to help trump
in order to give him a diplomatic
victory that he needed
uh with his dismal record of foreign
affairs
so that he could show something but it's
not only about trump because israel is
now offering its uh
newly found era france uh new technology
vital technology investment
opportunities
this deal also clears the way for the
for the united states to sell more
weapons
to countries in your region is that
really that irrelevant for the interest
of iran
aren't you minimizing the impact of that
agreement
minimizing the impact i'm saying that
this was
a travesty of justice to the
palestinians
but it wasn't a major diplomatic
accomplishment
these countries by persian gulf
countries
by 25 of total
global weaponry and they will buy more
i mean what have they done with this 25
of total global weaponry that they can
i mean let's make it 30 let's make it
40. let's make it 50.
what good does it do then so it doesn't
bother you at all but
it does bother me that our neighbors
are trying to buy security
they have been trying to buy security
don't forget
they tried to buy security from saddam
hussein and look where
they got with him they tried to buy
security from the united states
and they saw the united states simply
just leaving them in the cold
without giving them any protection now
they're trying to buy security from
israel which cannot even protect itself
against palestinians now
i think they're they're badly mistaken
they need to look
inward they leak they need to look at
their
own people for legitimacy and they need
to look at their own neighborhood for
security
now there are lots of speculations of
who is going to be next aman and sudan
are
talked about as the next countries to
follow
in the footsteps of the
uae but everybody is definitely looking
at the
saudi arabia and i think
you can see some subtle signs that the
public opinion is being massaged for the
formalization of what is already there
yeah for the formalization of what is
already there for i mean
saudi arabia and israel have been
cooperating with each other exactly for
years
and doing that in the open is that do
you think that's a likely scenario of it
actually happening i don't think it's
important
i don't think it's important i don't
think it it affects the situation
what is important is that i mean they
never helped the palestinians
anyway but we're not talking about only
palestinians
it does i mean the entire problem in the
middle east
is the trampling of the rights of the
palestinian people
you need to measure any development
with that yardstick whether it affects
the struggle
the resistance of the palestinians
towards
continued occupation i do not think
saudi arabia
uae or bahrain were strong supporters of
the palestinian cause
other than lip service so i don't think
it will have
any practical impact on the difficulties
in our region the difficulty
in our region is because of expansionism
of aggression and of violation of the
rights of the palestinian people
now president trump likes to
compliment himself on his new approaches
to diplomacy and
both his israeli and arab colleagues are
willing to give him that i mean they are
willing to give him
praise the photo ops while securing
their own
interests because i think they are not
losing out there
i know that iranians are proud people
but there is also a certain
degree of satisfaction in taking your
enemy for a ride
trump wants a deal with iran you know
that i know that everybody knows that
why not let him having it on your terms
there is a principle
that you want a deal that is not a photo
opportunity we have 159 pages
of a deal it's not a two-page document
that he can show in front of cameras
and i think it it is
in everybody's interest i'm not saying
it is only in our interest or only in
u.s interest it's a deal
it doesn't have everything that we
wanted it doesn't have everything that
the united states wanted
otherwise it would have been an
instrument of surrender
by iran or by the united states well you
cannot expect the united states to
surrender
you says that they cannot expect iran to
surrender so
i think president trump had what he
needs
you know he wants to call it trump deal
call it trump deal
but it is the best that can be achieved
and i'm not going to risk something that
i negotiated i know how hard it is
i'm i'm not just willing to
allow something that was extremely
difficult to negotiate
to evaporate just in order to satisfy
somebody's ego
but minister with all due respect my
question is not so much about the
americans
but about the israelis and the emiratis
do you think it's a good strategy do you
think
it's a clever policy of securing your
country's interest while
giving your partner or adversary
something that he wants and
at the end of the day a photo op as you
said is not that big of a price for
securing and
getting what you want why doesn't iran
try something like that
i don't speak for israel but i certainly
don't believe that the united arab
emirates
got what they require what they need
what their people need
had they gotten a bit of that they've
been promised a lot you know oh well
promises are promises promises are words
of math
you don't think that israel will pursue
that sharing technologies giving
opportunities wooing arab
neighbors into that orbit israel i'm
sure you
you believe that they will do that well
come on uh
israel has said that with our talent and
their money
we can get a lot i mean are they willing
to take that are they willing to buy
that
i guess not okay minister it's always a
pleasure talking to you thank you very
much for your time and
best of luck thank you and thank you for
watching hope to see you again
next week on worlds apart
[Music]
you